well apple in their developer conference
on monday made a big thing that the
ipad pro or the ipad in the new versions
of the ipad operating system ipod or 16
or whatever they're up to these days
is going to support
virtual memory or more accurately it's
going to support swap of virtual memory
so i thought it'd be a good idea to sort
of revisit or visit for the first time
depending on whether we've done it
before or not uh virtual memory and have
a look at how it works and why you might
want to add it to something like the
ipad pro
so my understanding
virtual memory is when you use the disk
for or something like a disk or
something extra for kind of storing
stuff you generally put in ram but
there's no spinning disc in an ipad what
is it going to make much difference so
that's that's a really good point and
this is two things so virtual memory
there's
what we tend to colloquially refer to as
virtual memory which is when data gets
swapped out
onto a hard disk to give you the
appearance of more memory but there's
also
virtual memory sort of technical sense
which is when we're talking about the
fact that the memory addresses the the
processes the programs running on the
device see aren't the same
as the physical addresses of where
things are actually stored in memory so
it's abstracted away yeah so the thing
is if we think about it if we've got a
cpu
let's say it's got
16 bytes of memory let's just go for
something simple because i don't have to
draw so many address lines of course a
16 byte cpu probably wouldn't be
much used for anything you couldn't even
store hello world in there and print
actually you might be able to store
hello world in there and print it out
you'd be pushing it to store that but if
someone wants that exercise to the
reader um
whether you can that could be the new
competition can you implement hello
world in 16 bytes
so we've got our luminous cpu with 16
bytes of memory and the way that the cpu
will access that is it has an address
bus or the equivalent of an address bus
buried inside all the way that modern
cpus work but we'll ignore that for now
and it can reference any of those memory
locations by giving a number so if he
wants to access byte8 it would give
eight as the address
which of course in binary is one zero
zero zero and so you get one zero zero
zero coming out there and traditionally
you'd have a block of ram
uh this is a 16 byte
ram
which would also have
an address bus on it
and
what we've got here is
the physical locations so if we specify
we want to access bike eight so we put
one zero zero zero on the address here
we're going to get the physical byte8
somewhere in this block of memory that's
in there go and watch some of the videos
we've done previously on how memory
works but
there's no reason that you have to do
that you could have some additional
logic in here which takes the address
generated by the cpu
and then translates it
to a different address in memory so we
could take the address from the cpu have
some additional logic which translates
it
and then
access a different address so we could
put eight in here the logic would
twiddle it around and what would come
out is two so we could say that
h
translates to physical location two so
this is the virtual address this is what
the computer sees what the program sees
this is the physical address of where it
actually ends up in memory and then we
could say well byte7 that maps to
byte1
byte6 would map to byte zero
and any translation you want now why
would you want to do that well let's see
we've got two probes using the same bit
of code they've got a shared library
in there well if you can map the address
from a virtual location to a physical
location
you only need to store one copy of that
in memory as long as they don't change
it but as long as they're only reading
from it you only store one copy but you
can map it to different locations in
each program so program one could have
it at address
let's say 42 program two could have an
address 84 and so on they could access
it at different locations but it maps to
the same block of memory and the
advantage of doing that is that you can
make your memory go further so you've
got say one shared library used by two
programs it can make your memory go
further but it's also great for lots of
other reasons because it means that
a program can have a consistent view of
its memory locations it can say start as
unix likes to do with the program
running at location zero
up until a certain point and you can
have the stack coming down from the
highest memory locations down and each
process that's running on the computer
sees the memory
like that even though they're actually
at different locations in the memory
because what's happening is that the
virtual locations used by
each process are being translated to the
physical locations in ram and what the
operating system do is we'll set up
those translations every time it
switches between the different processes
so that they each see that processes
virtual address space as we call it
where each things are laid out in this
virtual space so by the time that
request gets to ram it's actually mapped
to the physical location where that
program's data is
and does this the operating system do
it's not the hardware it's not the cpu
so it's both so actually this is
something that requires both the
operating system to do part of it
and the
hardware to provide the support to do it
so as we said we need some sort of
translation
between the addresses generated by the
program
and the physical locations in memory
this could potentially be a separate set
of logic you could have a separate chip
or discrete logic that implements this
or more likely these days it's what's
called the memory management unit that's
built into the cpu
that you're using so it's built into the
cpu but it doesn't have to be you could
implement it
manually and then what the operating
system does is it uses that technology
and it sets it up to translate things as
the program to switch from one program
to another is it possible you might have
it happening more than once so
it's been translated multiple times
theoretically there's no reason why you
couldn't do that
you'd have to ask the question though is
would you actually get any benefit from
it i mean if you've got
this block being translated to here by
one bit and then being translated to
here by another bit
that's the same as just translating it
in the first place so you probably find
that there's no real benefit from having
more than one
layer of translation in there
in most cases i'm sure there are some
unique use cases which will be mentioned
in the comments below where uh that is
absolutely necessary and things but in
the general case you wouldn't get much
benefit you probably would if you're
doing segmented addressing but that's
something else so once you've got this
translation in place you can actually
start to do
some really interesting things let's
have a look at an example of this let's
um let's move to a new piece of paper
let's suppose we have a program and
i'm going to give it 64k of memory just
because it makes things easier to think
in small amounts of memory not big huge
gigabytes i don't have paper big enough
so i'm going to divide this up into
sections which we call pages so rather
than doing the translations on every
address we actually sort of group them
together into what's referred to as a
page of memory let's have a look as an
example i've got memory here and i'm
going to treat this as a 64k
of memory so i'm going to break this up
into 16
blocks
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
we should have as we do 16
different
pages as we call them
of memory
now why have i broken that up into 16
well that's because each of these pages
is four kilobytes long and that has
traditionally been the size that we use
for pages on computers
why well if we'd broken it up and say 16
kilo byte pages we would only have ended
up with four pages at which point we're
dealing with huge blocks and if you've
only got 64k that's a quarter of memory
4k you've got 16th it's a nice balance i
suspect when this technology was being
developed things like the pdp-11
had a 64k address space 4k was a nice
dividing thing interestingly things like
the ipad and the iphone and the new m1
chips in apple's laptops you're using 16
kilobyte pages rather than 4k pages um
memory's got a lot bigger it makes more
sense and things work better using a
bigger page size and so i suspect we'll
see the default page size changing on a
lot of computer systems as we go forward
but what we've got now is this one will
be all memory that starts one zero zero
this is two zero zero and so on up to f
zero zero
up there
so we've gotta translate
a page
at a time so what this means is if the
program is using this
any address that's between zero and one
zero zero zero in hexadecimal
will get translated to an equivalent
location in physical memory
at
that location so let's say we want to
access address eight zero
zero zero when that address come which
is going to be there at eight zero zero
say we want to access a location here at
eight zero zero zero the computer is
going to generate the request
and when that's translated
because it's binary because it's powers
of two
actually we can just split the number up
in two so if i fold this piece of paper
like that
we have the lower 12 bits which specify
where we are
within this page in this case we're at
the right at the beginning
and then the upper four bits
because we're using
64 bits so we're using 16 bit addressing
that specifies what page you're in
so what happens is when the cpu makes
the request for eight zero zero zero
that goes into the translation logic
it looks at the page number and there'll
be a table somewhere in the computer
usually in
memory that is accessed as a fixed
location so look up eight in here and it
will say here that all these exist
at location let's say six
zero zero
in memory so it'll take that address
it'll see the eight there so okay i now
need to put that with a six
and so it can then
just concatenate those bits with the
bits and make up the high byte six
and it's got its location
for where it's it's like a magic trick
here we've got a location of where it'll
be in memory so the translation is
really easy
you can look up
the address there see where you need to
end up
and then you can put them together
to generate the new requests so you can
do that relatively quickly it doesn't
slow down the memory access
that much at all
but you can start to do interesting
things because
let's say that though that we've
actually only got 32k
of memory in our computer system so
let's say that we've got
the actual memory
here
let's say we've got the memory down here
but we've actually only got 32k of
memory it was expensive back in the
early 1980s so that would have been a
lot of memory the cpu can access 64k but
we've actually can only afford
32k
of memory so we've got our address that
we've translated it to
which means that actually we end up
accessing the address
somewhere in this block there even
though
we set the access
up there
now this gives us some interesting
opportunities
because
our cpu can access
64k
but we've only got 32k
now what we can do is say well okay
let's say that we running the program
and it's doing something so it fills up
that and that gets allocated into there
it fills up that and that actually gets
allocated into that bit there
fills up that that gets allocated down
there and so on
now we know that this is already
accessed and mapped to that bit
now if we access this bit
and we end up here
but now let's say that
we want to use some more memory
which is going to be this bit here
we've no space
with physical memory to actually store
that anywhere
the computer can address it because it's
got a bigger address space but we've
mapped all the pages
to different things already so we've got
no physical memory to do this
but because we're
translating things
we can start to do some clever things so
when the computer tried to access this
the memory isn't mapped to anything
and so the cpu wouldn't be able to
process it uh the translation logic
would say hang on i don't know what to
do with this there's no mapping for this
it would generate an error and then the
operating system
could take over and you could say well
okay actually this block of memory is
not being used i'll allocate you to
there and things in this case so it
can't do that because all the memory is
being allocated
so what's it going to do
well this is where
swap
becomes useful
because what we can do is say well okay
run out of physical memory
but i still want the program to do
what i'll do is i'll make a copy
of the memory
that was at that location
there and
which one it will use which page it will
use to evict to take out the thing it
will choose based on some algorithms
let's say
the one that hasn't been used least
recently is probably a good algorithm so
you find the one that hasn't been used
for ages and then you get through that
so it makes a copy of that now where's
it going to make a copy of it well you
can't make it into another location
memory because it's full but where you
can make a copy of it
is onto your storage device onto your
solid state drive your hard disk and
things in this case i made a copy of it
onto a piece of paper and so
we can put that to one size we can put
it into our storage device
and then the operators say well okay you
want to use this memory
that can now go
at address
six zero zero zero and it will update
its translation table
to say that addresses
at seven zero zero are now at six zero
zero zero and the addresses that were at
location
eight zero zero zero no longer there so
you can access the memory there fine
everything continues the far as the
program is concerned it's now using what
is that 36k of memory even though we've
only got 32k memory and because we've
copied the data out
onto
some of the storage we haven't lost any
data
now you could do this manually as part
of your program you probably run out of
memory i'll write some data out
to disk and
um then reuse it and things can do it
manually the advantage of this is it's
implementing the operating system you
just access memory and it gets handled
for you automatically now that all works
fine and it could happen again you could
access some other memory
let's say up there same thing could
happen things
but eventually
it's quite likely that you may go back
to editing to this bit of the document
that was addressed eight zero zero
whatever it was that was there you need
to access it
now you've got a problem
because that's not in memory
so when you try and access it the logic
that does the translation says hang on
this is no longer in memory
what do i do
yes we're trying to access the bit that
was eight zero zero the bit that we've
evicted earlier it's no longer in memory
so it can't do the translation in fact
if you look at the translation table
we've sort of blanked it out because
it's no longer there
what do we do
well the translation logic says i can't
access this
so it stops accessing it hands control
back to the operating system the
operating system say well okay
you want to access that a bit of memory
well i still have a copy of that i made
a copy of it it's on disk earlier
i will load that back into memory at
some location
now it doesn't load it back in to the
same point or it might well what it will
do is it will use the same algorithm it
will find the least recently used bit of
memory let's say it's this one here
and say
okay you want to access that
i will stick that in memory in this case
it's going to be address
zero zero zero
and so it will then
update the location
there to say that addresses from eight
zero zero zero map to one zero zero now
it'll then restart the instruction that
was trying to make that memory access
it gets translated down to here it gets
its data of course what it needed to do
which i missed out the step is that
before we evict that bit of memory
we need to make a copy of that
and store that on disk or wherever
to access it later if we need it and
where does that work how does the
operating system keep track of those
copies so that's down to how the
operating system is implemented there's
two main ways that you can either do it
you can either set up uh part of your
disk so if you use something like linux
you might see something like a swap
partition and that's just a partition on
the disk which has been allocated to
hold the copies and then the operating
system will copy the pages from memory
onto specific points on that disk
alternatively you may see a page file or
swap file which is just the same thing
but within a file within the traditional
directory structure on your system
now that's great and so that's what
they've basically
added
to the ipad uh in ipod os 16 is the
ability for it to
swap things out
except
not
quite because
the operating system on the ipad already
did a lot of this already
what's different
is that they now will do it with data
created by the program
because what people realized when they
started to
implement virtual memory and swapping
and things is that when you load a
program in to
memory the traditional way you do it is
you would go to disk where your
executable file is stored and you would
copy the bytes off the disk into the
computer's memory
buy it for a byte until the whole
program's loaded
which is fine but if you've got a big
program
let's say you're
using a word processor your wordpress
has got facilities to view a document
edit it there's probably a spell checker
in there there'll be support to print
things and so on so
rather large executable but if you're
just opening that word procedure just
quickly read the first few lines of text
in a document and then close it
you don't want to have to wait for it to
load in the spell checker and load in
the printing routines and things
so you could either break the program up
into small chunks which sometimes it did
but what people realize is that actually
this technology that they had for
swapping data in and out
for memory could be used to speed up
loading so what you did was you say okay
we'll load in the first page of the
executable file and start running it but
we set up the translation tables and
things so that all the other pages that
would be part of the executable
were mapped to the relevant part of the
disk so they're not using the swap area
now but they're relying on the fact that
actually the files on disk don't change
and so they're saying that this part of
the executable file will map here if
it's ever accessed and so they're doing
that
as they do that in fact in some cases
they went even further and started doing
compression on it but that's a story for
another time so the ipad supported that
so when you load an app on the ipad
it doesn't load it all in one go parts
of it are loaded on demand as it
accesses that bit of the program it'll
then page it in using the same
technology so it's a case of well it's
already on disk that data we don't need
to make another copy of it load it into
memory then page it out when we first
access it we'll page it in load it in
and then we can access it so the ipad
already did that so for executable files
the code that was part of them the data
that's stored within them could be paged
in
automatically and again if they then
started to run out of memory
it could page them out
and reload them when it needed them at a
later point
now why would you want to do this on
something like an ipad well
ipads are like any machine they have a
finite amount of memory i think modern
ipads have something like eight gigs 16
gig of ram
inside them
but they have 256 512 terabyte 2
terabyte of solid-state storage
and the advantage of solid-state storage
is very very low latency and access and
so paging things in and out is very very
quick if you old enough to remember hard
disks you could get to a point where it
ran out of memory so much there's so
many programs running at the same time
and that's when you really benefit from
virtual memory that your computer would
just sit there chugging
thrashing as it was referred to as it
was constantly swapping pages in and off
in and out off disk and your machine
would basically slow down so you had to
either go and get a coffee or something
or more likely turned it off and turned
it on again cleaned out all the memory
and everything worked a lot quicker
that's not why we turn computers on and
off again you've got sort of
nine milliseconds or something on the
average hard disk for it to access a
piece of data that's virtually tends
towards zero on a solid state it's not
zero but it tends towards it uh on the
solid state device like the flash memory
in a modern ipad or something
and so you get the benefit of having
more memory
and for some of the things that people
are doing if you're video editing if
you're doing high-end creation um you
can end up using a lot of data if you've
got lots of apps running then that puts
constraints on the memory 16 8 gig of
ram between
say 10 apps running is 800 meg each and
you can start to see that actually
having this ability to swap the data out
as well as swapping
bits of the program out can really give
you some benefits
for doing it so that's why they've added
this
only 10 years after they invented the
ipad
so the advantage so you are actually
seeing intel have and the name escapes
me that have looked at
uh
creating non-volatile storage it's a
little bit easier to find what the
factorization is and then once you've
factored it you can just do these steps
to completely calculate